I think there was confusion at the foot
of the union building expected to be
able to just walk up as soon as the
family had their private moment they've
now been told that they have will only
be allowed to take part in that walk
past if they go to one of three Park and
Ride venues all these people are walking
to one of those Park and Ride venues so
that they can catch when they get on
board that bus they will be screamed and
have their all their mobile phones and
electronic equipment taken off them that
is on the one hand to prevent to ensure
security and also culturally they do
things for tasty people take the body in
that state being screamed and all their
fingers will be marked to ensure that no
one tries to walk past the body twice
they're expecting as you were mentioning
earlier
satisfied enough that our president is
going to be buried in peace and South
Africa's mourning for the greatest I
call that as evolution we are said and
we are crying today we are going to
witness him we are going to see and we
are going to pray for him as well and we
hope that his spirit lives forever and
all I can say tell you Tata that's all I
can say thank you thank you I am because
of what ad for everything that I did was
to thank Pat for everything because I'm
his generation and why I am because of
him and his freedom thank you